liz cheney there are several things that
are a problem with her including the
fact that liz cheney bought a home in
wyoming in 2012 so that she could run
for senate against mike kenzie
that imploded and she was not able to
pursue that any further and then we've
heard very little from liz cheney after
that until 2016 when our congressional
seat came open and she came back to
wyoming to run for that liz cheney lives
in washington dc that's where her family
or not washington dc excuse me northern
virginia that's where her family resides
her husband works for a law firm back
there that does work for china by the
way we can talk about that in a moment
liz janey has very very very few ties to
wyoming i realized that her father
represented the state of wyoming
over 30 years ago but liz jamie's had
very little in very very few ties to
wyoming and very little interest in the
state of wyoming she talks a good game
but if you scratch her what you find is
she's very very shallow
you know i'm sure some people are
watching this going well wait dave even
if it's just an at even if it is the
at-large congressional district why are
you talking to a congressional candidate
from wyoming it seems a little obscure
from a national perspective but actually
uh here's the bumper sticker for this
episode
you are running against a woman by the
name of liz cheney now of course liz
cheney has become a sort of star amongst
the cnn msnbc crowd as a republican who
pretty much is against republicans and
you know she obsessed with january 6 and
the quote-unquote insurrection and
everything else
so i don't want to lead you too much i
might have done it already why don't you
give me your feelings on liz cheney and
how she relates to wyoming
liz cheney betrayed our state uh she
betrayed our country and i'll tell you a
couple of reasons of why i say that
because i know that's a fairly bold
statement but that's why i made the
decision to run against her i i've had a
successful law practice i've been
working for a non-profit law firm out of
washington dc for a while i love the
work that i do
but
there needs to be a change and we needed
to to put someone up who had the ability
to take on liz cheney and and with this
battle for wyoming and for our country
uh liz cheney there are several things
that are a problem with her including
the fact that liz cheney bought a home
in wyoming in 2012 so that she could run
for senate against mike kenzie
that imploded and she was not able to
pursue that any further and then we've
heard very little from liz cheney after
that until 2016 when our congressional
seat came open and she came back to
wyoming to run for that liz cheney lives
in washington dc that's where her family
or not washington dc excuse me northern
virginia that's where her family resides
her husband works for a law firm back
there that does work for china by the
way we can talk about that in a moment
liz cheney has very very very few ties
to wyoming i realized that her father
represented the state of wyoming
over 30 years ago but liz cheney's had
very little very very few ties to
wyoming and very little interest in the
state of wyoming she talks a good game
but if you scratch her what you find is
she's very very shallow she's very
shallow on the issues that are so
important to wyoming again our energy
issues are our life our
agricultural issues and then also the
regulatory issues over uh 48 percent of
our surface estate is owned by the
federal government and 65 percent of our
mineralist state is owned by the federal
government so we have a huge federal
footprint and the the regulations coming
out of washington d.c have been crushing
us but she hasn't done much to to
actually fix that
she does not represent wyoming and she
isn't representing our interests as far
as the january 6th i've started
describing it this way
we have separation of powers for a
reason and i know she keeps coming back
to that you are either for the
constitution or you're from donald trump
but you can't be for both that's a
binary that makes no sense whatsoever
and especially as someone who is
actually a constitutional attorney it's
actually kind of a stupid statement and
it's a stupid statement for a lot of
reasons including that it ignores the
vast you know ignores the constitution
itself but here's one of the fundamental
things i think people need to understand
about what liz cheney is doing
is we have a separation of powers the
legislative branch writes the laws the
executive branch carries them out and
the judiciary makes decisions uh you
know from criminal law to criminal cases
to
deciding you know disputes between
neighbors
what this commission has done is taken
on the role of all of them but most
importantly this january 6 commission is
acting as the prosecutor they're
presenting evidence to themselves as the
judiciary
and then they're at they are going to be
making the decision
as the jury
so they have actually subsumed in
themselves all aspects of decision
making they will decide what evidence
comes in and if it doesn't fit their
narrative we'll never see it it'll never
see the light of day um the fact that
they kept that that nancy pelosi what
probably most likely with liz cheney's
uh guidance
jim jordan of that committee tells you
from the very beginning that there was a
narrative that they were going to pursue
and that's what they're pursuing so liz
cheney spends all of her time she even
said it a couple of days ago do we know
that that was a fact i don't remember
that specifically do we know for sure
that she was guiding pelosi in terms of
keeping jim jordan and some of those
people off the committee
i don't know that for a fact but keep in
mind how much she decides i think we
have a lot of reasons to believe it yeah
yeah i think that it's reasonable uh and
the fact that she and adam kinziger are
the only two so-called republicans on
that committee they didn't want a jim
jordan and a jim banks asking questions
about well wait a minute what about
security that day why wasn't there more
security when did you know about this
were there provocateurs
in the in the crowd and who were those
provocateurs were there any fbi
informants where they're fbi employees
were there other people those are the
kinds of things that are never going to
be presented as part of this commission
so what you've got is you've got a
prosecutor who is is going to ignore any
evidence that doesn't support their
narrative presenting a case to
themselves to decide
what happened on january 6th and so if
you want to talk about being you know
unconstitutional or or extra
constitutional it seems to me that this
commission is one of the very first
places to start this is a star chamber
and their intent is to come out with a
report that they can hang around the
neck of donald trump and that they can
try to ostracize and uh those of us who
support him and conservatives from now
until the end of time that's the purpose
of this we know it and that's what she
spends her time on and we're embarrassed
she's using wyoming as the
uh the launch pad to give her the power
to do that
what do you think her her true angle is
with this i mean obviously she's getting
a lot of mainstream cred right they love
her because she's sort of what i call
the pet republican she does whatever the
mainstream wants and then that's the
type of republican they like and then
the second she does something that they
don't like then they're done with her
and they pick somebody else but do you
think her angle is purely because well
perhaps what you just said
about her husband but also because you
know her father was the vice president
there he's so entrenched in the swamp
that she's just protecting the thing
she's protecting the dc thing
regardless of what the constituents may
be in wyoming one i can't imagine a lot
you're hearing when you're out there uh
you know a lot of people going oh this
is the most important issue of the day
number one it isn't the most important
issue for the day for people in wyoming
i think that there are democrats in
wyoming who want to continue to bang
that drum but that just further supports
the position i'm taking on this as far
as her agenda goes i think that she made
the decision in the fall of 2020 and
perhaps even before that that this was
basically a battle between her and the
president trump faction of the party she
made the decision that she was going to
go after him and around november of 2020
she was the very first especially high
up republican that called for president
trump to concede and that the election
was fine that there was no problem with
it
so it was at that point that she
realized that it was either going to be
president trump and his followers or it
was going to be her and she started
rallying the forces rallying the swamp
to try to take him out keep in mind
she's the one that organized the letter
from the secretaries of defense saying
that president trump was unfit for
office why that's really important is
that she that issue was issued that
letter was issued prior to january sixth
it wasn't based on what happened on
january sixth i believe that they issued
that letter on january 4th
so there wasn't even anything to point
to so i think that she went all in okay
it's either trump or me and that's where
she is and i think that she thought
we're going to take him out this is the
kill shot this is going to be the end of
it and all they've done is they've
strengthened him and they've exposed
that the swamp and exposed themselves
for what they are
so i don't know what her end goal is i
don't know what her long-term plans are
uh being from wyoming i cannot imagine
why she would do what she's doing but it
obviously has to do with the fact that
people in washington dc think very
differently than we do out here in the
real world if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell